[Music]
what a pleasure to be here to present uh
my new book it is called a therapeutic
Journey it's a follow on to a book that
some of you might know which um I
brought out a few years ago and that was
called a school of Life an emotional
education and this is called a
therapeutic uh journey and it's really
following on from this exploration that
I've been on my colleagues been known at
the school of life for a number of years
into this very broad area which we might
call mental well-being um and it's
obviously a a vast topic um I should say
that I certainly don't believe that it's
possible for anyone to be sane is is any
is anyone in the room think that they
are sane just just let's just have a
show of hand anyone
who thank goodness um I'm very glad
you're obviously a very very sane
audience because in the paradoxical way
in which these things work the best
marker of having at least a measure of
Sanity is a friendship with one's more
insane sides and um the ability to
recognize the extent to which one isn't
entirely well and cannot be by the
simple nature facts of human nature um
this is about as good as we can ever get
if any of you dating a very useful way
to sift out those who you should
continue a meal with or not is simply to
turn to your companion at some point
normally after the starter at least and
say so in what ways are you mad and if
the person looks kind of puzzled and
angry and defensive and says how do you
mean mad just leave I mean put a little
bit of money down but quit the
restaurant but it's not going to work
it's not going to work but if they're
able to take the first steps into
outlining some of the ways in which they
may you know be tricky at points another
key question is to ask somebody if
they're difficult to live with if if
somebody thinks that they're easy to
live with again run run it's just this
is a very very bad sign so at the school
life we very much believe everybody's
hard to live with and everybody's insane
very good starting point but in this
book a therapeutic Journey what we're
looking at in particular is the darker
side of mental experience um and that is
the process of getting mentally unwell
it's taken us about you know 2,000 years
or so to even be able to mention what
should have always have been an
extremely almost Common Sense point you
which is that just as we get ill in our
bodies we of course get ill in our minds
there is no such thing as a life that
can be spent uh in a mind that is
entirely well we tend to like because
it's so frightening we tend to try and
create a wall a hard separation between
the crazy and the same well as you've
been as you'll pick up from what I've
been saying um I certainly don't believe
that that's the case that the border is
Shifting The Border is permeable and and
um any good and sane life will include
uh many moments of what one might as
well call insanity this is not a one-way
Street it's a constant passage between
um uh states of of distress of acute
distress and states of Greater wellness
it's worth maybe just summarizing or
just just trying to look at some of the
ways in which um a healthy mind operates
because all of us have moments when we
are able um to think in healthy ways and
it's you know especially when you lose
that ability to think to reflect on what
healthy thinking is it's really a
miraculous thing you know first and
foremost what a healthy mind is is an
editing machine what it is able to do is
to rank thoughts in order of importance
and not present Consciousness with the
full uh unalloyed
uncategorized um panoply of emotions
that it could feel at any time things
are ranked and things are sometimes
compartmentalized and put far away I'm
going to talk about defense mechanisms
in their more pejorative sense in a
minute but it's important to know that
the ability not to think of certain
things at certain points belongs to
health for example if there were
thoughts that I was having right now
about being here on stage I wouldn't be
able to continue my I may not be able to
continue much longer but I'm I'm going
all right for a few minutes but um if I
were to have certain thoughts like what
on Earth am I doing here what what what
about if people weren't nice to me what
about if if I didn't know what I was
talking about you all these things would
quite quickly trip me out and bring me
into a state where I couldn't do what I
could do what I can do so in other words
in order to function in the world you
need to prioritize categorize keep
certain thoughts uh at Bay particularly
punitive thoughts you know we are all in
order to keep going immense optimists we
need a boost of optimism all the time to
Bear ourselves I mean all of us you know
when we are so called down we we tend to
have those realistic depressive thoughts
goodness I'm rather ugly goodness I'm
rather strange goodness I'm so stupid
Etc now if those thoughts were allowed
to submerge us we couldn't get out of
bed there is but to at the core of
Health there lies a certain necessary
dose of optimism and it's only when we
lose that that we start to realize
absolutely how key it is not least we
have to forget on a daily basis that
we're going to die um philosophers love
to remind us of death and there are you
know real advantages sometimes in a
focusing way to remembering death but if
we really had to keep uh that thought of
death in mind as perhaps we should we
couldn't keep going so there's a lot of
thought a lot of thinking that we need
not to do in order to function as we do
but sometimes these very healthy
mechanisms of thought and processing
start to erode and for a period or
perhaps a longer Period start to break
down and we enter a state of mental
unwellness we're no longer able to
categorize our thoughts we're no longer
able to prioritize we're no longer able
to sleep we're no longer able to
therefore benefit from that restart that
a fresh morning um uh endows us with
when we're able to look again at a topic
in in in a certain way we become hyper
realists and that hyperrealism becomes
unlivable and at its worst life itself
starts to seem unendurable um I think
that you know many of us have at least
tasted a a share of what this might mean
hopefully um it was only a little moment
in life sometimes it can be longer I
would say that very few people get
through an entire life without at
certain moments slipping into these
kinds of territories and this is really
what the book is about those moments
when we lose our grip on all those
processes that the mind has in order to
be able to get us through the day now
why on Earth does does it happen um
there are stresses undoubtedly in daily
life um there are things that aggravate
a fragile mind but at the school of life
and this will annoy everybody so I'm
really sorry um we are very focused
unfortunately on
childhood um sometimes we leave we have
we run a YouTube channel and um almost
every film we make seems to mention
childhood and there's a few people in
particular who every time we fil go oh
look at them they're going on about
childhood again and I feel real sympathy
oh my goodness I mean we do seem to go
on a lot about childhood um it's really
boring to have to think about your
childhood many of us are 30 40 50 years
decades um out of childhood and still
here I am telling you that it's all
about your childhood well that's
extremely annoying and I really
sincerely apologize but the only way to
forget about your childhood is to go and
explore it we're not exploring childhood
for the sake of nostalgia or because we
love mommy and dad D or because it was
such fun but in order to get rid of the
thing once and for all you know these
ghosts of the Mind tend to be ghosts
that sprung on us in childhood and
without um the courage to go back and
look at them um we're unable unlikely to
find the freedom the calm the creativity
that we all um seek you know childhood
is I it took Humanity an unbelievable
length of time to recognize the role of
childhood in adult development I mean
you don't find any medieval person going
you know the reason I lack confidence is
my parents you know there's no ancient
Greek who's on record explaining their
behavior because of a parental shortfall
of affection it just doesn't exist there
is no record you know we have to wait
until the 20th century before people
speak in this way which can of course
lead us to a kind of Suspicion you know
are we somehow are we modern somehow
uniquely pampered obsessive in this area
I don't really think so I mean compare
it to our discovery of certain kinds of
bacteria you know it took until the late
19th century until the age of Freud to
realize that at a bacterial level there
are things that inhabit jugs of water
that on a bad day could kill the
population of an entire city that there
are macro biotic biological macrob
biological organisms that you can't see
with a naked eye that have the cap
capacity to kill millions of people and
it's so implausible and something akin
to this goes on in relation to our own
childhoods where again slightly
invisible processes are at play that
have the capacity to fell adult lives uh
in ways that are as destructive as a
certain kind of poisoning um part of the
problem of human beings is they have
such an inordinately long maturational
process a horse a fo is up and running
in you know an afternoon so if baby
hores mom and dad are slightly strange
or they are suffering from all sorts of
things doesn't really matter because
they're often often about within the
afternoon but we humans you know we're
at least 18 19 20 25 until we can get
away from these people and these people
are likely to be carrying all sorts of
distorted patterns which we learn with
some of the same natural inevitability
as we learn language you know none of us
learn our native language by sitting in
a classroom and slowly taking it in we
simply embi it um passively from the
surrounding environment while we're
doing handstands in the garden drawing
buttercups at the kitchen table we are
learning languages um that people are
speaking around us and it's not just
languages in the grammatical sense we
are also learning at all times emotional
languages who can we trust what is a man
what is a woman what is what am I what
is my worth um how what will happen if I
reach out and try and communicate with
another person all of these things all
of these conclusions the language that
we learn um is being taken in all the
time and it becomes a very dense native
language now of course we know um how
hard it is in adulthood to start
learning Finnish if we grew up speaking
Korean and how hard it is when you're a
native English speaker to pick up
Spanish you know we'll know that we've
probably got to go to language school
three four times a week we might need to
do it for years Etc people get very
impatient when you start telling them
you have learned certain a certain
emotion language and if you want to try
and correct it it's going to be a huge
labor you know you might need let's say
to go to therapy once a week even twice
a week and three times a week and they
go oh what are you kidding you think
I've got time to do that um surely you
can just you know read a book just this
the book will'll give it now this book
is a fantastic start but the bad news
the bad news is not enough it's not
enough even though it runs to 400 pages
and has you know a wealth of insights
not enough it's just the beginning of
the journey you're going to have to go
on but be patient with yourself as I say
think of how long it took you to learn
English or whatever language is your
native language think how complicated it
would be to change that language it's no
easier to start to learn a new language
of men and women and relationships and
self-esteem and confidence all of these
things are just as knotted and just as
firmly embedded uh in US um many many of
us almost say all of us suffer from what
nowadays is a little bit of a fash f
aable word but like many fashionable
words it has its use traumatized we have
all suffered trauma in childhood now
what is trauma trauma is essentially The
Experience uh an experience that is both
painful and at the age and at the stage
where where it is experienced It is
incomprehensible we simply cannot frame
it process it digest it or make sense of
it so it is swallowed in an undigested
form that is what it is to be
traumatized and as we know know and this
is one of the great discoveries of 20th
century Psychotherapy the only I think
the only way in which trauma can be
handled is if we go back and unpick it
and understand it and thereby process it
and let it um Liber and and work a
Liberation from its effect which we have
not understood you know most mental
troubles come from things that have not
been properly looked at anxiety for
example is worry that doesn't understand
understand itself depression is sadness
that has become unknown to us and
therefore has bled across the whole of
Our Lives irritability is Rage that
doesn't know its true Target you know
why when you open the drawer and you
can't open it and you get into absolute
Fury and you start hitting the drawer
and you go where is the damn key it's
not just me you do this too we all do
this too right um and then you think
hang on a minute it's not the drawer is
it now it's something else why why am I
in such a race R and that terrible thing
that we have to start to think I'm not
understanding myself I'm I'm diverting
Rage which belongs in one place and I'm
kicking the dog I'm kicking the drawer
I'm kicking the driver whatever it is um
many of our emotions do not find their
correct targets and the reason is that
their correct targets are extremely
awkward to come to understand for
example it's really nice to think that
your parents are lovely and you love
them of course you know that's the way
it should be so to imagine that you're
in a real Rage with them that's that's
kind of awkward or maybe you're in a
rage with your partner well that's a bit
awkward because you're supposed to love
them um brief diversion into sex why do
people stop having sex some of you
stopped having sex well um the standard
Common Sense view is this is just a sign
of time passing we go off people no no
no no we don't it's a sign of Frozen
rage um all of us upset our partners all
the time in quite small ways ways you
know partner comes home and goes got a
really interesting story to tell you go
just I just got to make a phone call you
pick up your phone and start looking at
something now your partner is not going
to you know scream at you probably
they'll just take it on the chin because
they've learned they're a good boy or
girl they've learned to be brave and to
be an adult but none of us are adults in
relationships all of us come to
relationships as essentially adult shell
three or four or fivey old inner being
and so when when Partners say to each
other grow up you want to go this is not
the game where you grow up you know
growing up is for the office the
domestic sphere the domestic sphere is
one where we can't help but bring a very
small toddler with us and that toddler
is extremely vulnerable and it gets hurt
all the time you know that slightly
cutting remark that you made about your
partner at a party quite funny everybody
laughed well they didn't laugh and now
it's 3 weeks later and they're still
pretty upset the problem is they don't
know they're upset why don't they know
they're upset because anger does not
communicate itself cleanly to us they
are out of touch with their emotions all
of us are constantly getting out of
touch with our emotions and a lot of our
so-called illnesses are the result of
Legions of emotions that have lost sight
of their true aim because we are not
very well equipped to repatriate our
emotions and find out who is that anger
really meant for and as I say some of
the reason for that is that the anger
that is due to certain people we think
I'm supposed to be nice so how could I
be in a rage with my mother she's really
nice she's very lovely she gave me a
Christmas present Etc um how could I be
angry with my partner they seem so you
know I'm married to them etc etc all
these things that stop us from
understanding the complexities of our
own lives and therefore end us up in
these kind of knots comeing back to sex
you know one of the things that happens
then is um when a lot of accumulated
anger that doesn't know itself has come
to Lodge in our mind Minds the last
thing we want is to be touched why would
we be touched by someone we're in a rage
with I don't want to be touched by
someone I'm in a rage with but thing is
we don't know we're in a rage the
partner definitely doesn't know we're in
a rage no one knows what's going on
everyone's reading a lot of books good
for penguin but other than that not such
a great time in bed you know quite quite
boring because no one knows what on
Earth's going on until maybe slowly you
find your way to something that says
might might I be in some ways in a rage
School of Life we make these cards these
dating cards we're supposed to take them
with on a date and ask your your your
partner uh all kinds of questions and
one of the questions which is
phenomenally useful such a simple
question you go on a date night with
your partner and you say to them is it
possible that I might have annoyed you
recently and how how have I annoyed you
recently and the thing is everyone
annoys everyone recently so it's a
fantastic question you can ask um and if
you're able to you know get it out over
dinner without hitting each other joke
joke we're not condoning um all sorts of
um bad behavior but if you can do it
politely with Grace with humor with
kindness you know none of us need
perfect Partners we need Partners who
are able to have an insight into their
imperfections and to communicate these
imperfections before they've done us too
much damage in a way that we can absorb
and vice versa that is a good a good
relationship so anyway um I'm I'm trying
to evoke the idea of a um a landscape in
which so much of what we've feel is
outside of our conscious command very
useful exercise to do to try and win
back more of the emotional territory in
the name of processing is to um at night
uh last thing at night to just make a
little bit of time to go back through
the day and just go what's coming up for
me here what am what am I feeling here
what are the emotions that I haven't
sufficiently felt and it could be rather
surprising thing it doesn't always have
to be bad things you could say you know
I was totally moved by the sight of a
tree at midday and I I just want to
think a little bit more deeply about
this or or maybe there is a kind of
regret that I felt and I've not been
able to process it all day so being able
not just to live but to make time to
process the act of living seems at the
heart of trying to do that process of
mental hygiene that seems so so
important um I was going to tell you
about difficult childhoods and um
sometimes people say we don't know what
a good childhood is who knows what a
good childhood is um it's so subjective
no one knows what a good parent is we
can't tell well I think that there are a
lot of
generalizations loose it's not a
scientific study but there are things we
can broadly say will be going on in a
good childhood a childhood that sets us
up well for mental well-being and later
life and conversely things that might be
missing from a childhood which will at
least aggravate the possibility of
reaching adult life in a more fragile uh
State um number one and most simply um
to feel that you are at the center of
the parental world for a time for a time
is absolutely essential to a feeling of
well-being there's a terrific anxiety in
some parents you know you can spoil a
child well look you can't really spoil a
child when a child is 6 months or a year
or two years you know then later on yes
you you know there are moments when of
course you can start to put boundaries
on the child's if you like egania but
the egoists the so-called narcist the
proverbial narcissists of adult life the
people who are grandiose these are not
the people who were made to feel like a
little emperor when they were one the
people who were made to feel like little
Emperors when they were one are very
happy in adult life to take their place
among everybody else and not stand out
the Disturbed people need to build
careers where they come on stage and
they speak to lots of people always you
know a sign if if you're a good parent a
sign that you're doing a good job is
that your child has no desire to be
famous if your child has a desire to be
known by anyone other than three or four
people something's going wrong pay them
more attention they're lacking right
they're compensating so um uh in a way
that that whole that whole narrative
that to give a child too much attention
creates an egoist I don't believe is
true in the early years or children need
to feel is that you know the universe
has opened up to produce them and they
are at the center they are the sun and
the moon and the stars and every time
they walk into the kitchen everybody's
delighted and every time they utter
something it's fantastic and every time
they do a drawing it's great now this
doesn't go on forever but in the very
early days this belongs to solidity that
is how you I believe how you solidify a
a personality um and part of what that
means is that a parent has to attune
themselves to the needs of a small
person now that's really weird and
difficult because small children are
really quite bizarre creatures the
things they care about the things
they're invested in are really
surprising to an adult mind but a a good
enough parent gets down on the level of
a child and tries to see the world
through their eyes a world in which you
know if no-no's eye has fallen off you
know noooo the pet rabbit if his eye has
fallen off it's a tragedy it is actually
a tragedy now if you stand back as out
go that's not a tragedy son it's going
to be you know there's going to be a lot
more tough stuff coming your way it's
true but it's not helpful all right
stoicism is a fantastic philosophy not
for the under ones okay it's just not
it's not brilliant this is what went
wrong with Great Britain this is the
history of Great Britain RIT large you
know boarding schools fantastic when
you're 40 it's called the Army before
that no Spar is that um so Attunement to
the needs of a of of a small child you
know parents have a very bad habit of
not quite listening to their children
and the reason if you have a child
that's very very noisy it's often a sign
that you think you're listening but
you're not quite I was um I was at a
Holiday Resort a few months ago and
there were some parents objectively very
nice and there was a child having a
little bit of a difficult time on
holiday quite a sort of nice resort by
the beach all very nice nice buffet
breakfast buffet and the child at
breakfast was saying child must have be
I didn't know three and it was saying I
hate it here I want to go home this
place is poo quite loudly everybody was
hearing this nice dining room was poo we
all looked at our plates a little bit
worried right and the mother uh was
saying obviously she meant well you know
we all we all mess up as parents but the
mother was saying don't be silly you're
having a lovely time it's the holidays
and this hotel's very
expensive I mean kind of sensible but
it's not not really listening and
similarly you know a child returns home
from school going Mommy Daddy I want to
kill the Headmaster I want to blow up
the school and the parent will go the
parents will go don't be so silly that's
ridiculous uh you know the police would
get you if you did that sort of thing
again that's not really what the kid is
saying really what the kid's saying is
um I'm really unhappy uh I want to let
off steam I'll be okay tomorrow but you
know ah I want to be in a rage for for a
minute and then I'll get better and you
know the ability to gift the child that
kind of airtime is that is love that is
the work of love and we can't do it all
the time anyone who's been a parent I've
been a parent you cannot do it all the
time but if you can do it sometimes that
is a wonderful uh gift incidentally
wonderful gift for adults too you know
we live live in a culture where people
are always going you know everyone's
speaking no one's listening what on
Earth is listening well listening is the
the great thing by the way if you um
it's Christmas coming up in a few months
and many of you be thinking what do I
get my partner Etc good news is here's a
gift you can give them simply write them
an IOU saying I will listen to you for
half an hour every day for a month I
could say half an hour a day a month
that's not very good but this is really
this is the luxury of luxuries but
you've got to do it properly now what is
it to listen properly so when the
partner comes home and says God I really
hate my boss they're so annoying and
they're so you know and and and the
other things that buzz in marketing is
an idiot and then the sales people are
awful and blah blah blah and I hate
everybody and and I feel terrible about
myself Etc and not listening is to say
look you know happened to me a few a few
years ago I was in sort of the same
position as as as you let me tell you a
few things first thing you need to do
get out of the pad first thing you need
to do is just like write down who the
people are that you're not getting on
with and then and then get a chart and
no no what you need to do is do a very
simple thing but very hard thing which
is to reflect back what they're saying
you simply need to find other words to
capture what they've just told you so
you need to go I'm hearing that works a
nightmare for you at the moment I'm
hearing that a lot of people that you're
working with is sort of driving you to
distraction and that you're feeling that
it's not very good for you and that
you're feeling kind of low about that
and I I hear that and you'll be having
sex tonight if you do that um definitely
definitely and it's going to really you
know boy things up right and it's so
simple but we go to the ends of the
Earth we do almost anything other than
do that so try that um what are the
other things that uh that parents uh uh
uh parents do um they understand that
childhood is full of odd phases that
children want all sorts of things that
but they're not threatened by the
childishness of the child it takes
immense inner maturity to be able to
tolerate the immaturity of of a child
also you know it's a painful thing to to
acknowledge but many parents do fall um
for envying their own children it's very
taboo what does it mean envy your own
children you're going to you're going to
envy your child you you know yes yes it
happens a lot in small ways and large um
and it's just you know probably all of
us who are parents who've been parents
have had moments where we thought hang
on a minute this kid is having a better
life than I am not sure I'm entirely
happy and we may small ways just want to
make sure that we're not too left behind
and you know it's a dark truth but the
ability to gift a child a better life
than the one you've had it's it requires
a lot of maturity and a lot of Courage
it doesn't come easily um the other
thing that a good parent is able to do
is to be a little bit boring um no one
wants an exciting parent the role of
mother or father you want to be seen by
your um children as predictable as
having no particularly you having a very
simple sort of life that you know all
your complexities that you wake up at
3:00 in the morning your kids don't want
to know you know you are a complicated
human being to be a parent is at some
level to be a skillful actor or an
edited down human because we simply in
order for a child to to come into its
own full complexity it doesn't need to
have the parents complexity always in
front of it and this is as it were a
gift not to have to reveal too much of
the agony of Being Human too early to uh
to a child um if a childhood goes well
the number one outcome of a childhood
going well is how the child feels about
itself not about the parents I mean
parents is that's another thing all
sorts of facts come in but all you need
to do is to wonder it's a very simple
exercise right how do you feel about
yourself whether you're a decent person
a good person an okay person deserve to
be on the earth or not right out of 10
who basically feels that they're in the
kind of 8 to 10 group like more or less
they feel good about being them who who
feels that they're more or less in that
category little show of hands of those
people okay good good and who's maybe in
the zero to three you know their life
may be going well but somehow they just
just don't really like themselves just
like the whole thing is rather who's
who's in that
group with
me okay okay so this gives you a flavor
all of us have had different childhoods
the story of childhood is refracted in
one's own estimation of oneself that's
where you pick up as it were how we feel
about ourselves and you know broadly
speaking a lack of love has made us ill
and it only really the presence of love
that can heal us and by love I don't
just mean um romantic love though
romantic love could be part of it it
could also be friendship and it can also
be
Psychotherapy um and um let me talk a
little bit about Psychotherapy um at the
school of life we're great very keen on
Psychotherapy uh this book is called a
therapeutic Journey but let me start by
saying they're probably one or two
psychotherapists in the room so with
apologies to them many many
psychotherapists are not quite how do I
put it um suitable for you uh they might
not be right for you um and so I know
many people who've said well I tried
that and the guy was so weird or you
know the whole thing was so odd I'm
never going back there again and I
understand that I think we have to look
at therapy a little bit like we might
look at dating in other words you you
don't go off the whole subject of a
relationship because you've been on one
date one bad date or two bad dates you
have to keep searching but many
therapists don't suit many clients and
so you have to kind of look around to
get a good fit but if there is something
that's really good about Psychotherapy
it's this so because of childood hood
and because of the language that we
learned in childhood all of us have
acquired expectations of how the world
is and how the world will respond to US
based on um certain things that happened
in the microcosmic world of the family
so we we extrapolate from what happened
in the family and generalize outwards to
the whole world it's a natural thing
that we do but it means that because our
families of origin are generally
carrying a lot of warps and a lot of
distortions we're likely to approach um
adult life full of expectations that are
not necessarily very fair either on
ourselves or on other people so for
example we may think that everybody
thinks we're boring or everyone's out to
get us or anyone that we try to love is
going to humiliate us or that in order
to um uh uh win anyone's favor we'll
always have to agree with them or
whatever it is we carry stories of what
what we need to do to get loved and also
what the what we can expect from the
world and these stories carry
distortions now normally we play out
these distortions in The Busy World of
relationships and the office and our
friendships and no one quite notices so
you know and also they're doing their
stuff back to us so everyone's kind of
projecting wildly into one another you
know someone's going everyone hates me
and the other one's going I want to
aggress everyone and you know it's just
a mess of of projections and counter
projections and no one sees what's going
on and there's no um reason or or or
ultimately forgiveness or reconciliation
but what can happen in therapy is you
take your issues and when it's going
well you play them out with the
therapist so you become really convinced
that the therapist hates you because
you're so boring and because therapy is
just a room with a therapist um the
therapist can actually observe that and
go no I don't think that's necessarily
right but I think I'm finding you quite
interesting the the therapist can see in
a kind of petri dish things that are
normally just lost in the complexity of
the the day-to-day world and therefore
there's a chance to correct what's going
on so that all those sightly strange
ideas like you know that um in order to
um uh get anyone's love we have to
entertain them all the time or or or or
whatever that these things are not
necessarily correct so we have a chance
in the the the sort of clinical and
clean confines of a therapy room to see
what we're doing uh and get a chance to
question whether it's still makes sense
it has an origin but that origin May no
longer be fair to reality as we as we
have to live it um and one of the key
things to to reflect on is that you know
we often see people who do things that
look a bit crazy right like we see
somebody and they're all the time I
don't know um not succeeding at things
they could succeed at or they are you
know pulling out of relationships that
looked promising or they are putting up
a wall when anyone tries to love them or
they're sabotaging their chances or you
know whatever and we think why they why
does that person do it it's completely
crazy there's no logic to it here's a
very important point there is always a
logic those behaviors which look in
inverted commas crazy Once Upon a Time
made great sense I want to go further
not only did they make great sense they
were very often the difference between
life and death between managing to
continue with life and giving up on life
we needed those patterns imagine imagine
the following scenario right imagine
somebody who grows up with a parent who
is suicidal right um they are
threatening suicide they suicide commit
suicide right how on Earth does a child
survive that experience right well one
of the ways that they might uh learn to
survive that experience is to shut down
completely right they will never ever
let anyone in because to let someone in
is to risk their own Annihilation right
and that when you're 5 years old to work
that out that is near on genius to work
out that in order to survive you need to
shut the drawbridge very tight fast
forward to 25 35 45 family Situation's
resolved itself in whatever way uh and
you've moved on and you're trying to
have relationship or whatever but in a
horrible way that defense mechanism is
still active and now it's trouble right
because now it means that when somebody
comes along and says oh we could have a
relationship mm no not possible because
the drawbridge is still shut so a lot of
the behavior that is suboptimal in adult
life once had a logic which we don't
understand and we're not sympathetic to
we don't even see it but if we can learn
to see that logic we can largely then
come to UNP pick it or imagine somebody
who let's say we all know these people
who can't stop joking around somebody
who let's say is completely optimistic
and sunny and even when something's sad
they're at a funeral they're like oh you
be and they're making a joke about the
casket and whatever and you want to go
where's your sadness what why are you
not able to get in touch with your
sadness that's what one feels right
there's a sort of um unreal relationship
to the world again imagine that that
former child has come through a journey
where one once upon a time it was
absolutely essential that that person be
the clown and cheer up maybe a
depressive mother or a father who was
you know very angry and um couldn't
couldn't find anything optimistic that
child needed to become a clown to get to
the next stage of life but now that
precise Behavior starts to be extremely
negative you know another thing that
children constantly do when children are
brought up in suboptimal surroundings
right with parents who maybe not that
nice to them um it would be devastating
to the child to have to see that the
fault lies with their parent right to to
to to imagine when you're a fouryear old
that your father or or or mother is
really not a very nice person and maybe
really quite Disturbed and kind of awful
right this is an unbearable thought and
this was the work of a pioneering
Scottish psychoanalyst called Ronald
faban wonderful psychoanalyst who
discovered he was working with very
deprived people people in Edinburgh and
Glasgow in the 1930s and he arrived at a
fascinating conclusion he talked to
children from the most deprived most
violent most abusive families and he
discovered that those children spoke
very highly of their parents they would
say my father he's a great man you this
is the guy who was hitting the child my
mother she's amazing mother you know
left the the kid unclean unfed for days
what was going on well in Fair Ben's
view um it's better to to think that you
are the problem than that you've been
born into a problematic situation so
what happens when you're in a suboptimal
parental situation is you start to hate
yourself and blame yourself and feel bad
about yourself because it is preferable
to the other bit of really bad news
which is to think that you've been born
into such an inadequate family that um
you may not survive it so this is the
way in which the Mind twists itself buys
itself peace but you know with with at
Great cost for for the long term many of
our symptoms it should say end up in our
bodies you know our minds our minds are
very frightened of insight and most of
the time they will try and ward off
Insight but there's also another part of
our mind that wants to know the truth
about our childhoods about our parents
about our caregivers about who we are
right and there's a constant push and
pull between the forces of repression
and the forces of honesty right and it
constantly is a a kind of tussle and you
know you can imagine it as a knock on
the door please please think a little
bit more give me some time to process
and if we're constantly busy um well
most obvious uh symptom is insomnia what
is insomnia other than the mind's
Revenge if you like for all those
thoughts that you tried so hard not to
have in the day that have come back at
3:00 a.m. because they need to be heard
what are certain kinds of bodily
symptoms other than messages from the
mind that haven't found a verbal
conscious mechanism of expression you
know when you're double doubled up with
back pain with lower back pain right
what's your back trying to tell you um
what are your shoulders trying to tell
you what's your stomach trying to tell
you our organs are very often the
emissaries of messages that we haven't
found a conscious way of addressing so
the body starts to be an organ through
which we are having to speak to
ourselves in a kind of code it's very
painful doctors can't work it out
because for a doctor what is lower back
pain other than a physiological uh event
when of course it it is a psychological
event or sometimes of course not not
always but sometimes it's a
psychological event that hasn't had a
chance to to understand itself um I
think we're going to have some time
quite a lot of time for questions and
answers and um and a chance to have a a
disc
um but really ultimately just to kind of
sum up the sort of drift of where I've
been taking you um think of Socrates who
at the dawn of Western Civilization he's
asked what is the goal of Life what is
the highest purpose of human beings
answers rather paradoxically very
beautifully know yourself right and
follows it up with the thought the
unexamined life is not worth living why
is it not worth living because the
unexamined life is that bit more painful
it's that bit less creative it's that
bit less stuck in patterns that we
didn't ask for and that are limiting who
we can be so Liberation awaits us when
we can have the courage to see that most
of us are in some ways bent crouching um
hedged in by aspects of the past that we
haven't yet had the opportunity to know
and that the prize of
a little bit kinder to oneself and a
little bit more connected to other
people at an authentic and sincere level
thank you so
much so thank you so much Ella we're
going to take questions in groups of
three so um I begin on that side
great so um I can't quite see you but
I'll hear you um so whenever uh whenever
you're ready
um first of all thank you very much
um for being um a person bringing an
inspiration and perspective um in my
life personally and and relationship
too um my question is related to your
initial remark around um anger and rage
um in particular in regards to fear of
an abandonment so I wonder um if you
have any thoughts or perspectives you
can share in that regard how to to
nurture um sort of embracing that aspect
of of emotions yes look it's such an
interesting question you know we hear
nowadays a lot about people Pleasers
right I sometimes think you know that
issue of anger is quite connected to the
issue of a people pleaser what is a
people pleaser it's really somebody who
hasn't been gifted the opportunity to
see that their own reality could be
acceptable to many many people at many
many junctures of course not always at
all times but that they've got such a
low threshold for accepting their own
ideas perspectives on things that the
only way in which they feel they can be
loved is to submit to whatever
authorities are around to agree and um
you know I think you'll be picking up
from just what I've been saying what's
what's going to be the history of people
pleasing again trying to educate you in
the role of looking backwards what's we
don't know exactly but the history for
people pleasa generally has a situation
where the truth of the growing child was
not acceptable to an adult and therefore
the uh child imbibed a view that the
only way in which to prove acceptable
was to shut up and accept whatever
happened to be around the Nazis are good
people oh yes yes very nice thank you
very much uh you know it's a great idea
to murder children in their oh yes thank
you yes because you don't have any
courage to stand up for your own truth
and you know that lack of confidence
which many of us know I mean you know
it's it's it's tragedy comic um is is
really the legacy of not feeling that we
could be ourselves and accepted you know
the wonderful psychoanalyst Donald winot
says it makes this great distinction
between the true self and a false self
and he says that a um a functioning
adult life has those true selves and
false selves in a good balance the true
self is what you really think what you
really believe what you really want some
of it is quite difficult and small
children especially if they're in a
loved environment will let you know
their true self quite sort of you know
vifer usly from a from a young age
they'll they they'll scream that they
want more more video they they want the
TV they they want to eat something they
want to stay up all night play have a
pillow fight Etc but they're letting you
know what they really want of course
adults can then have to accommodate that
in different ways but the the the the
the the way in which wiot interpreted is
that a false self should then grow up on
top of the true self right the false
self is designed to mediate between the
true self and the outside world so when
your boss comes along yeah you might not
want to tell them the whole truth when
you know someone you know when an
important guest comes to your house you
may want to slightly fake certain things
etc etc right we need a false self to
function in the world but in order to be
able to tolerate the demands of the
false self the true self has to have
been allowed a little bit of a runaround
and a compromised life is when that
balance is sort of out of sync so Health
means getting that true self FAL self
balance uh uh uh in order so to answer
your question um what you know what do
we need to do in order to have a a a
better relationship to our anger first
of all understand how is it that anger
came to be so frightening to us right
how did our own anger I'm not talking
here about violent Expressions you
sometimes we we shoot so far to the
other end we're not talking about doing
anyone harm we're talking about
registering a deep unhappiness with a
situation right there's the act of anger
and there's the feeling of anger and the
more we disallow ourselves from the
feeling of anger the more that uh that
feeling then has to emerge as symptoms
as symptomatic anger and that is
irritability uh that is insomnia that is
bowel troubles etc etc so make friends
with your own shadow side you think of
that very useful yian idea of the Shadow
side that there are many bits of us that
is currently in Shadow the side of us
that has slightly strange sexual
thoughts that is sometimes angry that
that wants to give it all in and move to
another country that that that has odd
thoughts about their friends Etc these
things are in Shadow in most of us and
the goal of life is to try and move as
much of what is currently in Shadow into
the light not in order to act on it
right because some of the reason why we
we we don't want to bring things out of
the Shadow is that we think that if we
do we'll have to act on it no no no
there's an enormous difference between
tolerating a thought and acting on a
thought and come back to anger the
ability to tolerate the thought of one's
anger is the beginning of an easier
relationship to one's very legitimate
sense of frustration with the
world I've heard it said that um the end
of suffering is the beginning of
wisdom and um I'm wondering what you
would Advocate to get us there does
everybody need to be on psychotherapy
um uh does everybody need to be in
Psychotherapy um yes and no um I mean no
in the sense not everybody needs to go
to an actual therapist you know 50
minutes a week or more um not
necessarily but I think everybody has to
be involved with a word which is in the
title of the book what you might call
the therapeutic which is in other words
an aliveness to um well number one you
know what's the Bedrock of psychotherapy
the unconscious right that that very you
know sometimes it's so it's so
ubiquitous we forget what an
extraordinary idea Freud bequeathed the
world uh at the beginning of the 20th
century when he posited and and it sort
of sounds odd surely humans had realized
this before and they sort of ish had but
not really that most of mental
functioning is unconscious in other
words there's an enormous amount of who
we are what we want what we feel that we
don't know about um and for Freud's you
know again the Bedrock of the
psychotherapeutic is um a lot of the
material that is unconscious causes us
trouble um it has been driven into the
unconscious in order to spare us pain
but long term we buy that avoidance of
pain at a very high price and that a a
good life is one where are able to
stomach as much of our own truth as
possible and the only way in which we'll
be able to do that is about another
words that's key love love for ourselves
love that we've been shown by others
kindness that is the tool that's going
to allow us to tolerate ourselves rather
than tear ourselves apart or build walls
in our mind between what we can see and
accept and what is simply um too
appalling given how we feel about
ourselves
go for
it just have a question in the back
there y hi sorry yeah here um hi thanks
Alan that was really brilliant talk uh I
just wanted to know to what extent do
you think people can wake up and just
have a bad day and the reason I asked
that is because there are some days
where I wake up and feel that my
neurochemical was off balance and I seem
to just hate the world so yeah I just
want to know what are your thoughts
about that yes I mean absolutely and you
know you you you talk about an imbalance
at a sort of chemical level you know I
think one of the things one of the many
things that we have to kind of accept is
that we are these strange creatures
where our big brains cohabit with a body
which has certain needs and demands and
you know sometimes this particular era
of of sort of people who spend a bit too
long in their own brains that you know
Suddenly at certain point they'll go
there is no meaning to life all humans
are cruel there is nothing worth living
for all of my careful reasoning leads me
to suppose that existence has no purpose
or meaning and you're thinking H why is
this person reasoning in these sort of
thoughtful ways towards such negativity
and the reason could be that they're
really taking a survey of reality and
that's their conclusion or they're
missing 3 hours sleep they're 3 hours
Short of sleep and that's why they're
coming up with all these theories that
the relationship's broken they hate
their children the Nations going to pot
Etc it could be that they need an orange
juice quite fast right and and sometimes
especially as you know thoughtful people
we underestimate the claims on the body
so we should never get so clever that we
deny the possibility that our clever
clever thoughts are really just uh an
out the outcome of as I say a shortage
of of glucose or or or something like
this I mean parents of small children
know this you know when a formerly Sunny
child is like you know dancing around
and doing wonderful things suddenly goes
I hate Mommy I hate daddy I'm going to
kill myself they don't quite say that do
they but um that sort of thing you know
gets very tragic
um a sort of novice parent might
panicing oh my goodness I've I've got to
got to try and help the child to make
the world and you know and a more
experienced parent goes right nap time
straight to bed half an hour nap it'll
all be better in half an hour so we
remain you know key Point Key point you
know keep you know we're Russian dolls
right and there is there remains an
infant within us and that infant
unfortunately gets tired and when it
gets tired it gets very tragic and the
best thing that the parental side of us
can do is go right we're going to go to
bed we're not thinking any more of this
I'll address this in the morning if it's
still so pressing okay we'll call
schopenhauer n we'll read daycard Etc
but probably it would have blown over
and we can we can move on I
think um thank you for that um that was
as insightful as f as always but um um I
wondered what do you think are the
drawbacks of um Psychotherapy because as
a society we're constantly sort of
incentivized to look inwards oh um if
you're feeling bad do some mindfulness
do some yoga have a gratitude journal
and so on so these are the kinds of
solutions that were given to us to
things like the pandemic and I wonder it
kind of promotes this belly button view
of a world where we're constantly
looking at ourselves in the mirror and
the mirror and the mirror and there's
some step where you have to look
outwards and act in the world and
actually help your neighbor and and do
some volunteering and do things that
don't necessarily uh focus on you and
what you are but how we can change the
world and things out there so where does
the boundary lie between introspection
and action yes look such a good question
and you know I I I couldn't really give
it justice but but look I'd say that
um the goal ultimately Psychotherapy is
not more Psychotherapy it's to be done
with the whole thing precisely so that
one can then look outwards um the thing
is that there's no point saying to
somebody who's mentally unwell pull
yourself together stop thinking about
yourself so much it's like you know the
last thing the person wants to do who's
in a wretched State of Mind is think
about themselves the reason they're
thinking so much about themselves is
because they're desperate that you know
they would love to forget all about
themselves and to go off and be an
active member of society so we have to
be a little bit careful in saying you
know because then gets to boarding
school stoicism of like you know what
person should just pull their socks up
and get on with life and you know they
would love a mentally unwell person
would love to get on with life more than
anything they just can't and then the
question is what do we do with that
person and yes sometimes an orientation
towards outside can jog the Mind towards
you know A New Perspective absolutely
but if a problem is rooted somewhere in
the psyche and somewhere in a in in a
story of trauma and difficulty um you
know I I'm revealing my my prejudices I
I think that the only game in town
probably is going to be to take that on
board you know because if I come back to
the language acquisition Theory we have
acquired a language and we're going to
have to try and correct that language
and the only way to do that is to notice
we're speaking it um and simply as it
were're changing the subject while
sometimes helpful um I think you know is
is um you know could be tricky but look
I I'm aware this is a very difficult
subject and you know I am I'm
generalizing and you know if if some of
you thinking hang on a minute that
didn't work for my friend or you know
blah blah blah I get it I get it this is
this is me generalizing and it's you
know it's the it's it's the the sort of
perils of um standing up on a stage and
and coming up with um with with clever
sounding sentences it it it's very newas
and and I think you know it's important
to say the field of mental unwellness is
incredibly complicated and requires huge
sort of care as we move across it and um
and and it's something that you know um
I try never to forget that there are so
many angles so many so many different
cases etc etc and so part of it is just
um having as much experience trying out
as many things as as as as a right for
you um because they really it is hard at
some point for an outsider to say that's
going to make you better that and only
that very very hard very hard
yeah hello hi Alan and thank you for the
wisdom thank you for the questions I
have a practical one now that I have
your book I'm wondering who did you
write it for did you write it for the
parents to make sure that we're not
traumatizing our kids or did you write
it for the kids to try to deal and
rewrite the story and the patterns um
well you know it's going to be a sort of
silly sounding answer but both both
because you know what is a parent other
than a former child and what is a child
other than a future maybe parent or at
least caregiver or person you know who
will one day have authority over
somebody and a capacity either to harm
or or to help and you know one of the
painful things about about life is that
of course there's intergenerational
transmission of problems and many of us
are really dealing in our adult life
with the problems with which our parents
were grappling I mean interesting
thought exercise think about you know
you won't have a scientific answer to
this but if you just sort of as it were
try and imagine maybe tonight lying in
bed shut your eyes and think what were
my parents grappling with what you know
if I had to try and sum up what were the
main challenges of my parents' life
maybe you know they had to I don't know
achieve a certain kind of status or free
themselves from their parents or assert
their Identity or create a you know
whatever it may be and then think well
what's my relationship to the parental
struggle
and you know there's a there's a sort of
eerie frightening poignant way in which
very often you know the kids are trying
to help their parents in in in some way
or the problem that is was in the parent
has found a form within the child and
the child is trying to deal with it and
trying to heal the parent the parent may
be long dead but still the child is
trying to think about what might have
helped the parent so I wrote this book
for my
parents
hello hello
hello hello yeah hi alen thank you for
your talk um I found your um Insight on
being therapeutic uh in examining the
unconscious very very insightful um my
question is the way we frame mental
health um compared to physical health
today and tell me if that comparison is
wrong um when we talk about physical
health Health we talk about physical
health but when we talk about mental
health we're talking about mental
illness uh we don't talk about physical
health just about diabetes or heart
diseases or knee problem we talk about
endurance flexibility strength and all
sorts of that but when it comes to
mental health we just talking about
problems no good markers to know how we
are progressing with other equivalence
to strength endurance so would you share
some thoughts on what do you think is a
good mental health not talk about um
traumas and others things yes I mean
such a good question sounds ridiculous
but I know we do have a list in this
book on what mental health is because I
I couldn't agree with you more
absolutely 100% um you know it's such
things it's such Maneuvers as for
example um the capacity to forgive
oneself and this could sound odd what
does that mean forgive oneself well but
literally to to not um uh relentlessly
return the mind to its worst moments um
this belongs to health um the capacity
to achieve perspective on things in
other words to to grade issues and to
assign you know a one to one a three to
another a 10 to another but not to have
everything as a 10 the ability to grade
problems um the ability to sequence
thoughts so that not everything um is
coming at you uh at once that you're
able to to create as it were an order
line for your thoughts um and that
you're able to devote sustained energy
to unpicking certain things without
being overwhelmed by the whole lot I
mean they sound rather banal and you
know they are quite they are quite Bal
but they're the bedrocks of mental
well-being and it's only when mental
health goes we think oh my goodness I
cannot stop thinking as if it were today
about an incident 12 years ago I'm I'm
now and 12 years ago have have stopped
um you know or that you're unable to
stop having an argument with someone who
died 30 years ago you are still having
the argument in your head you might be
waking up in the middle of the night
saying that's unfair and you're speaking
to a dead person right this is what
happens to people whose Minds have
slipped out of their normal control that
that time and the and the ability of
time to sequence emotional events has
has disappeared um so anyway there
there's a whole long list of factors but
you're absolutely right to draw our
attention to it you know can we as it
were go to the gym and do exercises in
this area as we can yes and the book has
some um but also it's it's also about
gratitude to to just work you know when
you are feeling okay notice what you're
doing notice what you're doing that
you're able to say ah I'm going to get
on to that tomorrow morning I don't need
to do that now or ah I don't need to
give myself such a hard time this is
mental health in action um and you know
sometimes we think mental health in such
weird terms such diverse terms you know
whether it's going to a clinic or an
everyday form of mental ill health some
of the same factors are at play and it
is about essentially destroying oneself
and there are many many ways of
destroying
oneself yeah think just a probably
couple of couple more
questions hi yeah I was wondering how
much you think these ideas can be taken
to a societal level you started your
talk by saying how fundamental optimism
is to mental health and it feels like
part of what's so broken in society at
the moment is that we have fundamentally
lost the faith we've lost the ability to
collectively imagine a better future and
indeed that it feels like a deliberate
political tactic to Prey Upon that
malaise and their overwhelm to produce
the worst forms of paralysis or nativist
politics or kind of defensive and cruel
politics even in the worst cases and I'm
wondering how you think a a society can
examine its shadow self what that looks
like in practice and how you come out of
the other side um look I I feel your
passion and unfortunately I share it you
know unfortunat I mean I wish I didn't
but I I I I fear you're absolutely right
um uh the causes are many but um you
know we know that bad news sells we know
that alarm um uh gets eyeballs etc etc
so the forces of kindness the forces of
calm the forces of perspective are now
more endangered than ever the forces of
optimism the forces of utopianism the
forces of imagining a better world all
of these things are you know in in
Retreat um look I would say it's
individual by individual if you're a
parent every child that you manage to
raise in the world who ha who is
self-possessed who is calm who has a
measure of optimism who has not been so
badly treated that they need to treat
others badly is a win you know and let's
let's let's U really try and understand
this we live in a society of widespread
sadism sadism is a defense mechanism
what is sadism sadom is something H bad
happened to me it's intolerable that it
happened to me what's the way that I'm
going to deal with it I'm going to make
life hell for somebody else right I will
take my injury and I will put it on
somebody else um masochism is also
difficult but there's less masochism
around we're much more a sadistic
Society where we're constantly doing
past the parcel with our wounds um and I
think you know at a psychological level
I mean you I I I noticed that your
question is political and I could answer
it politically I I'm going to because of
where we are today I'm going to answer
it psychologically and as if you're
psychoanalytically every time that a
human being enters adulthood having felt
a reserve of Love they don't need to be
sadistic towards somebody else they
don't need to get their kicks from from
passing on cruelty and and that's the
beginning of societal change and a good
Society is one ultimately where the
balance between those who need to make
others suffer and those who are feel
good enough about themselves that they
will be enriched through kindness when
that balance is is in trained so I've
answered it psychoanalytically as I say
I know there's a political angle as
well
hello so I hope I can articulate my
question well but please correct me if I
don't my question is about uh trauma and
childhood and I was just wondering if
our bodies sort of pick and choose the
traumas they want to uh basically uh
keep the score of and remind us of 30 40
years later and the reason I ask is
because I would be talking to someone
and i' mentioned what I think is a a
normal and just general thing that
happened in my life and they'd be
appalled but then I would be really hung
up on things that other people would
find ridiculous that Mak
sense I I didn't fully understand so you
think that people people's assessment of
what is a traumatic incident feels quite
subjective I think you're saying right
there is no there's no sort of um rule
book about what is considered a trauma
and I think I think that's correct that
um you know it it it it is um you know
what matters is how an incident was
interpreted and felt by an individual um
and and different things will affect
different people because you know the
context is very uh different for some
people you know a parent will leave and
that's okay because the surrounding
environment was such that you know that
could be born that absence could be born
for others it may be you know a a tear
through their life which they'll be
wrestling with until the day they die um
it a lot does depend on the
susceptibility of the individual and and
what else is is is is going on which is
why you know I think the um I think we
should be very careful to grade other
people's traumas for them to say that's
not serious you know and again parents
do that you know parents will say um you
know uh you know baby tiger toys lost
its tail and the parent will say to the
child don't make such a fuss it's only
the tail you know it doesn't matter it's
only the tail of a toy for the child
when you're two maybe that tail is
everything right so careful because we
just don't know how others are kind of
taking things particularly very small
people um and um and it's very very
subjective um on that note time is
scking by um so what I really want to
say is an enormous thank you to all of
you for for coming by I want to thank my
editor uh a man called Simon prer who
works at Penguin Books he is a genius
among Publishers um I'll tell you why he
publishes more people who for a long
time no one's ever heard of until they
become Superstars for years Simon prer
published a writer called Bernardine
evaristo who's one of the most famous
writers in Britain now win prizes etc
for years Simon published Bernardine and
no one noticed and Simon said this
person is worthwhile for years he
published a writer called Ali Smith one
of the most distinguished amazing
writers in Modern English literature no
one read her for years and Simon said
this author matters why am I mentioning
Simon Simon is an example of a man with
a true self right he has to work within
a publishing conglomerate he's got
bosses Etc basically he gets a hunch and
he sticks with it because somewhere in
Simon's past sorry Simon to think about
your childhood someone probably said
yeah your intuition is right he was able
to hang on to his true self and that's
how he publishes and um I'm immensely
grateful my whole career is really owed
to a few others too but um was really
owed to to Simon and it was he who said
you could take some of these um uh uh uh
ideas from the school of life you could
put them in a book so thank you Simon
for um for uh making a therapeutic
Journey possible and um thank you to all
my colleagues at the school of life for
doing what they do it's an institution
that day and day out helps people in
therapeutic ways come and visit us you
see us find Us online schoolof life.com
um and um if you get this book hope you
enjoy it um and I hope in some way it
jogs your mind on a therapeutic Journey
thank you also to everybody at the howto
Academy for making um tonight possible
most of all thank you to you
thanks